folks joe derosa here
let's talk about live dates and other
things i got the plugs coming at you
houston texas
come and take it festival at the secret
group may 19th and may 22nd i'll be
shooting my new hour
called i never promised you a rose
garden two shows only intimate tickets
are on sale now they're going fast grab
yours while you can i'll also be at the
creek and cave in austin texas uh may
20th and 21st not shooting those shows
but running that same one-man show hour
i actually i'm looking at this as a
one-man show versus just a stand-up hour
uh not that it's any better or worse
than a stand-up hour it's not a
competition i'm just saying now i see it
anyway come on out uh i'll be uh in
other places coming up soon i know the
punch line in july is happening in san
francisco tickets aren't available just
yet but they're coming soon and of
course stop by joey rose's in new york
city when you have a chance 174
rivington street we're open tuesday
through sunday full bar and killer
sandwiches go to joeyrosesnyc.com
for any information you need there and
if you want to buy tickets to those
shows go to joederosainfo.com
all the merch is available right now
links are in the videos links are on our
social pages merch is finally out uh if
you go see him may 14th at the red bank
you can't see me me may 14 to the beacon
but it's sold out
so you can't do it anymore you know what
go see steve burns go see somebody else
may 14th steve byrne yeah may 21st in
san diego may 22nd at the wilton in los
angeles and uh july 15th at the virgin
uh theater in in las vegas all fun stuff
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds folks
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds taste buds taste buds
t-a-s-t-e
my man is here today i'm gonna take my
shoes off take your shoes off mr brian
quinn the mighty quinn
before we even get started
i brought something for you
oh you did well not not really like uh
[Music]
i don't want to get too excited but i
watched a movie last night and i said to
myself it was so [ __ ] weird and i was
like there's this i want to bring the
dvd and give it to some to you okay
saying someone like i'm not like i'm
gonna reveal that you're the person i'm
giving it to like because i want you to
see you might have already seen it
but um i thought like you could watch it
and then like one day when i come back
not this one like you could talk about
it or you could text me later about it
this is so funny dude
i watched this last night and i just i i
need you to watch it this is how by the
way
99 of the romances in woody allen movies
start like this
where a guy is like i thought of you and
i would like you to listen to this and
tell me what you feel dude dude hold on
a second what hold on a second what pimp
this what is about to happen i can't
even i can't believe what is about to
happen what's happening hold on a second
cue just handed me this blu-ray death
game of a game a movie called death game
yeah hold on
no way i as i watched it i was like i
must
i must get derose to watson what is this
movie about it's
it's so all right so this is the movie
it's about uh they me they remade it
with canneries a few years back where
this guy is family guy he's got a wife
and kids and his wife's gotta leave the
house with the kids for the few days and
then his doorbell rings on a stormy
night and it's these two like super hot
young chicks who come in and their game
is they try and seduce dudes and if the
guy
is like look i'm married um then i guess
the guy's life doesn't get [ __ ]
upturned and tortured but if he does
[ __ ] him
they stay then they don't leave and they
they [ __ ] with them and they screw with
his life and and uh yeah so that's death
game and it's like it's like a cult
it sounds like a grindhouse cult classic
here it is he's already got it he's
already got it
all right okay dude
i can't believe you just pulled that out
okay so i mine's unopened still yeah i
watched mine last night
mine was unopen until yesterday so look
at this all right because i bought it i
bought it when they announced the
special keychain i got the keychain
so how how did you find out about it
because here's the thing i have a
subscription to this magazine room work
okay room org i read i have fangoria
okay uh but you know i i know rumor is a
little more hardcore correct than finger
oreo maybe i don't think it's more
hardcore i think it's more for the
collectors oh okay um it gets because
fengori is a little more like interviews
and movie reviews and that seems to be
the just the bulk of it right at least
room org has some of that but they get a
lot into like there's there's
there's full like here the horror
related books that came out this month
and they do a special section on each
issue i think this is the issue with
death game but they do a special section
where it's called like unearthed and
undead or something where they talk
about a movie that was that was deemed
lost that after
you know a long process somebody got
this thing got the rights to it and it's
finally getting it re-released in its
proper whatever
and i read the one about death game and
i was and it said grindhouse is this
company groundhouse is releasing it and
i was like
i got to buy that man like this sounds
so clever in the wild right i just
bought it on blind faith that's i did
the same exact thing i i don't know
where i read the article but i i i'm on
like all sorts of mailing lists and
stuff right now i've ordered from before
um and i guess maybe i just got the
email about it and i was like man that
seems
why do you guys love horror movies so
much what's up why do you love horror
movies so much oh i mean you're
subscribed to magazines about it i've
never heard of these yeah but that's uh
the same reason like anybody likes
anything it's like it's it's
we're talking about yeah yeah it's uh i
think uh i but i i don't know about you
i like them personally because i find
them to be a great escape from reality
it's the same reason i like video games
it's like i like stuff that takes me out
of it which is why 99 of the horror
movies i watch
are either supernatural or so insane
that it's absurd like this is probably
so insane it's absurd
it's bad [ __ ] yeah it's so crazy that i
was like i gotta bring it to joe i gotta
come for you i gotta bring it to joe
because i want you to watch and get your
opinion on it and now i don't even have
to worry about i could bring that home
with me
dude like you're the only person i know
that even has even heard of that movie
and you've heard it in the same way i
did where it's like you heard of it just
bought it because yeah because the the
whole article hunted in here was like
this movie is [ __ ] out of its head it
is the [ __ ] i i you so brian johnson
came over last night yeah and we watched
death game and we watched the remake
with canna reeves they made a few years
ago
knock knock yeah okay i didn't know that
that was a remake it's a remake eli roth
made it and uh
it's you know it it's a remake it's not
as crazy i mean it has anna darmis in it
and she's like going like full-on
seductress mode so it's like it's great
to watch don't get me wrong but it
doesn't it's not the bat [ __ ] and the
ending to this film is one of the
craziest things i've seen i i'm like you
ha you must watch it and then you get to
the end of the cannery's version that's
like oh it's not they they totally like
yeah all right suddenly there's a moral
lesson sprinkled in and and
yeah you're like uh
forget it yeah i imagined when i read
the article they must have mentioned
that it was remade into knock knock and
i just didn't catch it or something i
can't believe they wouldn't say that i
think the best horror movie of all time
is
i i the exorcist is my
my ride or die like i
i the exorcist is so good to me and so
scary to me that i won't watch it i'll
only watch it every few years because i
don't want to get used to how scary i
think it is that's what happened to me i
like really like cherish it it's one of
the few videos it still scares me a
little bit did you like the directors
like when they went in and added the
spider walk and all that [ __ ] you like
that you like that or you like the old
one better i like that version
especially after i read the book the
book that that version
it is so close to the book it's crazy
the only thing they omit from the book
is there's one reagan scene
that's that's very sexual she does
something very sexual oh yeah and like
and
even
even with the [ __ ] they put in the movie
i was like i get why they cut this out
of the movie at the time they were like
this is too much just too much but um
and she does it like to taunt the priest
and it's it's a pretty rough scene but
aside from that
the only thing in the book that was cut
out of the movie is there's a subplot
where you think where the detective
suspects that the butler
killed
the jur the director that kept calling
him a nazi
oh okay because remember reagan kills
him yeah and
they just they're just in the movie
they're just like we don't know what
killed this guy he's dead though right
in the book
beca there's that scene in the movie
where he's taunting the butler and
calling him a nazi in the book
the butler has this like secret life and
you think that the butler might have
murdered the director okay and then you
find out that the butler's secret life
is not sinister at all it's that he's
got a family he's taken care of
so he's like quietly taken care of so
he's always always like sneaking off to
take care of them
so it's not interesting for a movie a
horror movie an atmospheric car it
wasn't important enough of a character
in the movie that it would have just
okay you know that admit the book the
book is way more like
like it it spends more time on like we
don't think that this demon thing is
real we think that this is a psychotic
break of some kind
they they speed through that stuff and
that subplot is part of that whole thing
they speed through that in the movie to
get to the good stuff but other than
that
the movie is so identical yeah it's
crazy i have i i mean i wouldn't say i
got lucky in when i'm when i say this
but like i had ordered this like
leather-bound
tome of that and legion is uh the sequel
right reading legion right now oh okay
so i had so i was on my bed we're dudes
kismet today baby dude look at us
i don't even know what we're supposed to
be arguing so so like i ordered like it
was this this you know how they do like
super fancy versions of books i have
like hitchhikers guys to the galaxy
so i got it because i was like i want to
read it and like let me get into it and
then like two weeks after i ordered it
it comes signed by william blatty
he died two weeks after i read it so i
was like oh [ __ ] man that sucks that he
died but like this is definitely going
up in value right holy [ __ ] yeah so it's
pretty pretty you know i'd rather he be
alive than
the book go up like 50 bucks in value
but go to shopping pimp let's see what
this thing is that's the one
right there yeah if you just holy [ __ ]
that's going for six hundred six billion
oh i bought that i bought that pre-death
price would you pay for it i don't
remember but i know for a fact that's 95
yeah 600 bucks for it holy [ __ ] yeah
that's wild oh so that's so oh so you're
reading legionella the movie legion
i love it is so [ __ ] bonkers it's
scary it is i love it i love that movie
and i have the sh the scream factory
release
where the first disc is exorcist three
okay and then the second disc is legion
when legion is the is the william pewter
cut yeah which got all the the lost
footage yeah and everything i saw i seen
that version i'm not sure which i prefer
to be honest but but
it's funny the scariest parts in the
movie i don't think are going to be in
the book like i don't think they're
going to describe
a lady comes out with scissors like yeah
it sounds goofy like when you when you
when you say my friend uh my friend uh
uh jessie popp who's a very funny comic
he had such a funny joke about john wick
oh yeah and he's like he's like i love
those movies just like you know they
were books first because
what's that like read the john white
book and he's like he's like he's like
john wick is fighting a guy
now they're in the bathroom wait no now
they're back in the kitchen they're in
the bathroom again he's punching a guy
with a book he's punching a guy in the
face with a book it's crazy
like harry carry running the [ __ ]
commentary
but um
i love legion the book is the book is is
vibes a little more like a murder
mystery okay but it's very dark it is
creepy
and
the detective character in the book is
awesome and it's fun reading the book
after you saw the movie because you
could picture george c scott you get to
pretend it's him in your head right
and the character is so funny dude he's
so he's so funny in the book there's
glimpses of it in the movie like when
he's like when he's talking to his buddy
like his uh who's a cop friend over
there that guy that walks around with
him yeah yeah yeah and he's always
breaking that guy's balls and he's like
yeah and he's like you know
i bla i ble i bless you my son you're
now anointed you're disgusting like he
talks like that in the movie a couple
times but he talks like that through the
entire book okay and
in the book they talk about how he
always carries books on him
so he like his trench coat he's always
pulling books out and he just talks like
that and he goes on these pontifications
that are so nuts but like so brilliant
it's an awesome book i'll start reading
it it's an awesome book we have a book
club now yeah yeah yeah
yeah read that and uh i wish i was done
with it i'd just give it to you right
now i haven't i haven't well probably
not if it's 600 bucks i'm probably not
gonna oh that's right you have it in the
i'm not gonna crack open that i don't
know i'm sitting on that yeah don't sell
that right now and anybody out there
yeah 100 bucks
have you guys ever known anyone how to
get an exorcism in real life
no
silly um
i know a little bit about it
because my dad's a deacon
oh really yeah my dad's a church deacon
and um in catholic the catholic church
and he's done them no no no we have a
guy tell him steve dave who who's part
of like like the pittsburgh
he's the guy that the church calls to
for exorcisms he's a deacon that's wild
and he comes on the podcast and talks
about it um
you know i like the guy he's an honest
guy you know so i don't think he's lying
uh so if you take it on his own terms
then it's it's fascinating
it's fascinating stuff i was writing a
script with a friend of mine it was the
first thing i ever wrote
and it never nothing ever happened with
it but whatever we wrote we were writing
a script it was an anthology horror
movie it was called the devil knows me
was the title and it was all devil
related stories but the wrap around was
about an exorcism
so i remember i called my dad and i was
like getting information from him yeah
about how it works and one of the
interesting things he told me at least
in their
diet
diocese
diocese dice diocese diocese
whatever the hell it is anyway he was
like we don't know who
when he was at the time he was like we
don't know a lot of them you don't know
who the exorcist is they keep the guy
anonymous
like oh wow in certain
in certain regions i guess that's just
what they do and he's like you know they
don't call attention to it
um because i guess because it could be
exploited so easily
okay you know what i mean like i guess
if people knew like that guy's the
exorcist yeah you could just
call him be like i i got a problem you
know because you have to go through so
many you also have to go through so many
tears to get an exorcism approved right
so but
it was really interesting i was prayed
over as a kid for being a bad kid yeah
my parents had it
my parents had a prayer group and they
prayed over me what did you do what was
the tipping what was the inciting
incident to this what was the final
straw that they're like that's it i
think i told my mom that he'd go to hell
it
wasn't
remember kids would do that when you
were little like no kids
i knew a kid in my neighborhood that
chopped the head off a turtle and like
the entire neighborhood yeah just turned
like
ostracized them yeah kids would like we
had bad kids in my neighborhood and they
would like they would like they would
like put like firecrackers inside like
frogs
and [ __ ] like that it was it was i mean
i never saw them do it they would just
they would talk about how they did it
hopefully they were just bullshitting
i don't think so these kids were pretty
sick i wasn't allowed to hang out with
them i remember
when i was a kid i had like goldfish and
i had like a fake um
like house in the fish tank and i wanted
the fish to go in the house so badly i
must have been like eight or nine so i
took the fish and i put them in the
house and when i was putting them in the
fish died i guess i broke the goldfish
back and i cried for
days days
i'm sure my my parents thought there was
something wrong with me
i i felt so bad about it no i remember i
used to go fishing with this i used to
go fishing a lot when i was a kid it's
something i want to do again i haven't
done it in years but um i used to go a
lot as a kid and there was a kid i was
friends with his name was billy
something my mom and his mom were
friends
and on fridays we would go to his house
and my
my mom and his mom would hang out with
me and this kid would go fishing he had
a pond near his house and i remember we
went down one day and these you know
like the bad kids in his neighborhood
um
bad kids just to digress for a second
bad kids in the suburbs were so [ __ ]
sick like like if you watch stephen king
movies and read stephen king books he
depicts it perfectly yeah the bullies in
those movies are like that is what
suburban bullies are like like they're
sinister yeah they're pretty sinister
actually that was one of the failings of
the it movies like the new ones yes one
of the families was like these bullies
aren't that scary yeah i agree
i mean dude the bullies in christine are
it's nuts man like it's
anyway
those kids in his neighborhood i
remember they had a fish that they
caught and it was alive and they were
just like throwing it like into like
the ground and against rock and it was
wow and like we were so like we were so
like disturbed like that that memory
haunts me to this day it makes me
and i remember like looking at the kid
and we were both like just like this is
horrible but like you couldn't say
anything these kids would have beat the
living yeah like that we would have been
dead dude the damage is done the fish is
already smashed against the rock the
fish and quite active the fish was
asking for it a little bit yeah it was a
bit of a prick that fish
fish opened
but no these kid the kids like that in
my neighborhood that i was talking about
that blew up the frogs
one of the kids used to tie scissors to
a string and swing them around like this
and go near like literally he and let it
get
let the radius of it get wider and wider
to like scare you as you got farther
away from him they they were sick were
they at that what do you think like 12 i
think these kids were about 26. they
were
they were like and they're still now
they're out there right now yeah they
were kids of their own and they're
little pieces of [ __ ] that's scary yeah
yeah i know i i i i hate i'm actually
getting sick to my stomach to what uh
what are we debating let's why don't we
jump into the day i'm sorry because
you're reminding me a story of your vibe
no i saw like these neighborhood kids
throw a rock at a squirrel once and they
hit it and the squirrels like mate was
so upset and screaming and crying and
like how you said it haunts you it just
reminded me that and like my stomach got
a little nauseous and and like people i
i i fear people are going to think that
i'm that we come on here and then i
bring the vibe down no i feel like i
brought you back no but you don't talk
like this with sal right
we and shall get into all kinds of stuff
yeah it's usually more personally uh
yeah it's usually more personally aimed
at what
to to defame one another with sal
you got a great energy i can't you know
not that sal's got a bad energy but but
we bring it out of each other for some
reason uh yeah i never knew that the
exorcist and the church make 35 grand a
year
yeah i guess so wait what that's what it
says here they think that's a pre-salary
yeah
they get salaries i thought they had to
like no they they have to get salary
they get some money yeah they do they
have a salary
well that was a great thing justin
farrell my high school they they would
they i believe i remember them telling
me that they got a salary but they also
get put room and board and stuff like
that oh yeah that was one of my when the
scan when the catholic church scandal
happened with the altar boys
dennis miller oh my god it was one of my
favorite jokes he was like he was like i
always
i always
priest always freaked me out to begin
with if i'm gonna be honest and he goes
hey what's that guy's deal
no chicks no money ever
what could go wrong there
[Laughter]
that guy's going to get tons of chicks
and tons of money like you could see
that going wrong right right yeah you
just need like to find the middle it's
both ways my dishwasher keeps beeping
but what are you gonna do nothing we're
not gonna do anything about it um battle
today is yeah you know what i think this
has been such a lively discussion so far
i think we should do steak versus
chicken no okay we're gonna save it
steak versus chicken is the next step
we were doing three apps total with my
man cue here yeah he stepped in sally
babe um he tweeted out about it it's no
secret he went down with the vid
for a minute and our schedules got a
little screwy because of it things got
pushed back
so because of that uh q kindly stepped
in to here to help us make up for
something well i guess i haven't seen
you in a while i want you to come like
it's it's more about seeing you than
helping out if it's
gonna be clear i appreciate that hold on
i gotta i gotta i gotta stop that
babble babble babble
usually babel's a bad word well in this
case babel's a good word babel's a great
sponsor here why i like babel they're
helping you learn a second language all
right uh we've all all tried learning a
second language some of us took to it
some of us didn't like me
whether it was in high school or college
or or whatever
the language classes weren't exactly the
high point of my academic career i had a
hard time
getting it
now thanks to babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you're going to be
traveling abroad or just you know maybe
you want to connect in a deeper way to a
family member maybe you just want to
have some fun and learn a different
language doesn't matter
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world hey if you live in a city
like new york like i do a second
language can come in handy a lot of
languages are spoken in this city
outside of my first language english and
it helps to be able to communicate more
it's i it and and beyond just in in a in
a a
functional way uh it helps just in
improving your lifestyle and connecting
to all different types of people it's a
beautiful thing babel 15-minute lessons
that's how they make it a perfect way to
learn a new language on the go other
language learning apps use ai for their
lesson plans you know babbles their
lessons were created by over 100
language experts real people
uh their teaching message method has
been scientifically proven to be
effective plus babel's speech
recognition technology helps you improve
your pronoun pronunciation pronunciation
and accent
anyway right now you're going to save up
to 60 off your subscription when you go
to babble.com taste buds that's b a b b
e l dot com slash taste buds for up to
60 off your subscription babble language
for life hello
fresh
hello saying hello to you the fresh
hello fresh
good to see you fresh hello fresh it's
hellofresh
all right here we are we've talked about
them before we're going to talk about
them again why because they're great
hellofresh getting you the farm fresh
seasonal produce and easy to make
recipes delivered right to your door
every week
we get it we don't have time to get out
there all the time we don't have time to
stop at the store and buy the meal we
should be eating at night
uh we don't have time sometimes to stop
at the store to buy the meal we could be
eating a diet and more importantly we
don't always have the time to prepare
the meal we should or could be eating at
night or in the day if you want you
don't have to do these at night
and that's where hello fresh comes in
okay it's been a tough year with this
pandemic some people don't feel fully
comfortable going back into the store
great here's a service that's going to
bring you the ingredients all the stuff
you need to make a great
meal ingredients travel from the farm
straight to your doorstep in under a
week so they're always fresh
always without a trip to the grocery
store as i said or the farmer's market
it's all about convenience here hello
fresh's uh chefs really know how to
diversify the menu also which is
important you want good food to be
diverse same thing all the time you're
going to get tired of it you're not
going to want to do it you want to keep
it interesting and fun seasonal recipes
like salmon limone or pasta primavera
these are the kinds of dishes you're
going to get they're going to help you
do that
you can pick from your favorites pick
your favorites from 50 different weekly
options you can skip neat weeks if you
need to you can change your delivery
date you can update your preferences all
in the hello fresh app i love an app
an app helps customize your favorite
dishes with the new hello custom
offerings by swapping out one protein or
side for another i love that maybe if
you're on a specific diet or something
and you can't have one thing or you have
an allergy whatever or maybe you just
don't like something you can mix the
switch and go well i'd like that but i
don't want it with the with this
specific thing
man guy they are laying this out for you
they're making it as easy as possible to
eat right and cook quick in your home so
go to hellofresh.com
tastebuds16 and use tastebuds16 to get
up to 16
free meals and three free gifts that's a
hell of a deal
okay
hellofresh.com slash tastebuds16
and then use codetastebuds16 to get up
to 16 free meals and three
free
gifts
that's it hellofresh america's number
one meal kit um
hugh was just mentioned the artwork
while i was off camera like these were
on yeah because the set of the special
was was night gallery it was the rods
earlier it was a take on night gallery
so then we had these paintings made the
artist did a really great job very good
do you remember
a restaurant in new york city called
night gallery no it was um
it was in the west village and it was
when you walked in it was all paintings
like this under black light and stuff
like that the same people that own um uh
jekyll and hyde check on high they had
like four of those oh that's cluttered
lamb jekyll and hyde one more and night
gallery and it was kind of cool and then
i went out of business slaughtered lamb
is that a american werewolf in london
yeah you've never been in there it's
like you go and they have like werewolf
statues never put that together oh yeah
you go in they have like skeletons all
over the place so like touristy and [ __ ]
like between the two of them if i was
you i'd go to slaughtered lamb it's a
little more off the beaten path yeah um
and it's just like a regular bar but
it's horror themed jekyll and hyde's
gone no
pretty sure i think it's closed yeah get
out of here i don't think night gallery
is still around no night gallery is long
gone that i know jacqueline hyde closed
after all these years um
yeah put put r uh
but there were two there was one oh no
wait a minute and the one in the west
village it's open seventh avenue yeah i
thought it was closed because i don't
remember seeing the sign last time i was
down there oh that's great that's good
that it's still open um slaughtered lamb
you know what i never went in because
from the outside i thought it was just a
run-of-the-mill irish pub no it's it's
all horror theme there's like dioramas
and life-size dioramas
not that i don't like an irish pub but
no i never felt like when i was walking
by like oh i got to go in this place you
know yeah i think slaughtered lamp
started as like a touristy trap thing
then just it's been open for decades now
so it's not anymore it's just kind of
like a local horror themed bar oh that's
so cool yeah like i like it i i've i
it's one of my go-to's in manhattan oh i
love it man yeah i gotta go there
but uh i'm gonna take a date
take it down the old slaughter sleeve
yeah i'll find a you know i'll find one
of these goth girls take them over there
you don't yeah it's not really like you
walk in and it's not really a horror
crowd
uh yeah
people aren't dressed up and stuff no
not really but you see they got the
skeleton on the roof right there already
outside
i must not i must have my head up my ass
i would have noticed a skeleton on there
yeah maybe i've never walked by this
place yes slaughtered lamb one of one of
my favorite bars in manhattan where's it
at it's in uh it's uh westville it's in
the it's in the west village off of uh
where's that movie theater that netflix
up bought right across from the cages
oh they bought the ifc center it's right
around the corner from there okay yeah
yeah
i thought yeah that's where i thought it
was i must have whatever all right so
all right this is what we're debating
what are we debating we're doing we're
we're back in effect folks we're doing
the first ever rematch on taste buds
two first today on the taste buds
program
the first ever rematch yeah and the
first ever time
me and brian quinn are hosting together
cause you've hosted a bunch with sal yes
uh when i'm and we always appreciate you
stepping in you're like that you're like
the taste buds guest host now i'll take
it it's a fish i have fun um i feel no
pressure
oh look at that somebody put we're doing
the rematch of weed versus alcohol
people okay the last time we did it a
friendship and a podcast almost ended
whoa got that serious it got ugly over
weed and alcohol
yeah and you know who brought most of
the anger
the weed people
oh this is cool
i've i fought against weed i fought i
fought on behalf of alcohol but you're
again you generally are not a weed guy
right
i used to be used to be i'm not anymore
okay which is why today's battle is
going to be interesting
because i'm going to battle four-weed
today all right to show this audience
i'm a good sport
and i do see its qualities okay i just
don't partake in it much anymore okay by
much i mean i i i might maybe eat a five
gram edible once a year
that is a low amount for new york city
in the in the year of our lord 2022. and
i got to be cocked on booze before i do
it yeah i if i did that right now just
five i would i would freak out out of a
panic attack what do you lose to
hangovers because i went out for drinks
the other night with my my manager and i
had three martinis which does not sound
like like for me that doesn't sound like
a lot
but then the next i didn't even feel
that drunk like i felt like a healthy
buzz but nothing out of control or
anything like that and the next day i
could not get off the couch i was
vomiting oh wow and i vomited i used i'm
telling you i would just start getting
so dizzy and i would go throw up and i
was i'd be like this is [ __ ] nuts
because i always consider myself a
fairly accomplished drinker
you are i've drank with you
but i mean i'm i'm having a similar
thing happen now mine's medicine related
because i'm on some anti-anxiety meds
and stuff like that okay um they're
working
sort of
they are to an extent yes okay let's put
it that way but i also have an
incredible amount of anxiety-inducing
things on my plate right now you know
everything i'm doing is a question mark
around it you know i open the sandwich
shop at a bar
i do stand-up comedy
you know i don't have anything that's
just like this is secure don't worry
yeah i mean if it makes you feel better
like i don't think it ever changes i
mean
you don't feel even after all the
success you don't you don't ever go it's
like it's gonna be okay
no you know why it gets into like
existential crisis then like there's
something switches when you go from like
survival to like what's after like oh
all right i mean i guess i could just
[ __ ] chill out and like you know work
every once in a while we could tour i
mean the same [ __ ] you're doing like
like when you once you're not worried
about that path like you're like i'll
figure it out it's more of a confidence
of like i'll figure it out it's not
really about money in the bank it's more
about getting to a place where you're
like if i ever needed to do something
i'll figure it out i said to my parents
when i was home at easter i just said
listen you know uh
i should be happy like i should be
ecstatic you should i've fulfilled so
many of my dreams at this point and
they're all going pretty well like it's
nothing is disastrous nothing is failing
and i go and
everything makes me anxious still like
it's like it's just but also i think a
lot of that is is the environment we're
living in i don't i think people have
ptsd from covet and oh i for sure yeah
it's a wild scene out there so yeah it's
a little crazy um but um
oh anyway medge okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
so i'm on meds
they affect my alcohol intake greatly so
now my thing i noticed
i have
if i have five drinks which i know a lot
of you will go wow that's a lot of
drinks for me that's that doesn't sound
like a lot to me right
that's nothing to me
five drinks now will put me
almost on my ass like where i'm like
where i'm like i gotta get out of here
like i'm starting to get like messy you
know as your friend
that's upsetting to hear
as as your opponent on beer pong i'm so
[ __ ] excited
and i hope that your weakness maintains
throughout the summer so that i might
finally crush you
because i can't stop thinking about that
beer pong i talk about it all the time i
can't get uh you're in my head you're
living rent-free right there i'm not
even ashamed to admit it i think about
it all the time how you just decimated
me that's so funny dude and i was with
so we have
you've talked about this on on this show
before this show tell them steve dave
i've talked about it everywhere but yeah
q and i have a very healthy uh uh beer
pong rivalry and the other guy i have it
with i was the other two guys i have it
with you're my number one adversary but
i also have like why you keep beating me
you just beat me it's like i'm all
whipped dog it's great though
it's great it's great for me ever you
know what i beat him once uh and i took
the title from you and i had it like
three hours and then he just sauntered
back in the pool and took it back
i remember the most
mad i ever not mad
i just bring it out of people i bring
the worst at people
i have a gift
because there's no enjoying the game
it's not like it's not like i was just
in the pool he'll like he'll get in your
cup and then like he'll be like drink
and then it's like well i was gonna
drink it anyway but now this
[ __ ] is telling me to drink so
now i don't want to drink even though i
the reason i'm playing the game is to
drink because the [ __ ] away he is it
makes me not want to drink but i have to
drink uh i get a yeah i drink it i get i
come from a
i come from a beer pong school of
getting under the other person's skin as
much as possible like that's how we
that's how we always played it like me
and my buddy scott
who's like my oldest friend in the world
who've known him since we were literally
babies we we would we would play at
parties as a team right like like where
we didn't we knew like one person that
invited us or whatever so we were
playing against strangers and we
like literally like one time these girls
ran around the table to hit us they got
so mad at us because we're being so
obnoxious like not like not
about gender or anything we were just
being obnoxious opponents
the millennials aren't going to come
after you right now
we weren't being like hey honey nice
skirt like we weren't doing anything
like that how was their skirt by the way
was it nice i don't remember yeah oh
[ __ ] face i don't remember
but also who's that kid on snl um kyle
uh
oh god
kyle
mooney yeah kyle mooney mooney yeah so
kyle mooney is really good friends with
my buddy nick rutherford i think they
used to be in a comedy group or
something together and nick rutherford
was one of my best pals when i lived in
l.a we used to hang out all the time
nick's great uh and i went
[Music]
flying with nick at a party and i played
kyle mooney in beer park and
he had a he had a beard at the time and
a hat like that with the hair coming out
and i kept going hey spielberg nice
[ __ ] shot you stink right i kept
calling him spielberg and he got so mad
he just walked he just left
[Music]
and i was laughing sorry i was like
brother i pissed off your boy moody
something fierce what is inside of you
that makes you want to do this like why
can't you just play a game there's
something about beer pong where when
you're
you're loot when you're winning it's so
glorious
and when you're losing it's so
infuriating be i think because you're
having to to drink and you're getting
drunk it feels like a punishment yeah i
didn't it didn't until i played you
like it just felt like it was just fun
it's not like flip cup it's you know
there's tons of drinking games out there
where you can get plenty drunk yeah
quarters whatever
beer pong is different it's it's when
you're losing
it is a direct punishment that that is
connected to your skill all right so
you're getting drunk and you're going i
don't want to be this drunk but i'm
losing because i'm not playing
skillfully enough sure and it just sets
a great stage from [ __ ] talk it's just
an amazing stage for [ __ ] talk in my
opinion i'm not asking you to stop i'm
not going to like that's that's like my
job is to like beat you my job is not to
crumble
and to ask for you to [ __ ] go easy
and stop playing my game is to my job is
to beat you at your own game and until i
accomplish that it's on me so i was last
night with mcgill send you into the west
my friend
in disgrace i'll send you to the west in
disgrace when i get when i get my full
powers i was with
i was with mcginley ryan yeah and the
other joe last night yeah
they came to joey roses and we hung out
and we were talking about beer pong
because those are the other two guys
that i played on that trip beside you
that also i annoyed the [ __ ] out of
um and ryan was talking about how his
parents have that his family has that
house down the shore okay and he was
like we all gotta go and i was like i
made him take out his phone and set up a
week in july and he's gonna start
reaching out to she was available
but that was the whole thing i was like
we gotta go we gotta play beer pong in
the pool we gotta do this dude like like
i was so excited man yeah it's coming
excited yeah but now now due to your
medication
your game might be off i plan to be off
of it by then okay all right so you're
gonna be a basket case but you'll be at
the top of your game [ __ ] beer pong
that's how it was last year
all right i'm excited when you're
winning at beer pong you're not too much
of a basket case you're feeling pretty
good about yourself uh all right there
it is there it is
um
yes but back to what we were saying
this is by the way what i knew was gonna
happen what's that with today with the
with the with the episodes because i was
like well what do you guys what do you
want to what topics you want to talk
about and i was like it does not matter
like it doesn't matter to me at all like
because i know that this is the way it's
going to go with me and you shall um
you know what i'm going to save it for
the next episode okay because
just i'm going to
should i tell them
yeah just tell them why not
okay well because they don't know
because it's not a pulled episode
oh okay should we just drop it as a
surprise you might just do a surprise
sure yeah all right we'll do it all
right okay all right i'll i'm gonna save
that story until okay okay
anyway um
so all right so here's the thing okay we
gotta do the chat the battle chat do you
know what it is it's b-a-t-t-l-e butts
do we do that already in the beginning
that's we did the t-a-s-t oh okay got it
ready yeah okay so here we go ready yep
b-a-t-t-l-e
buds all right
team weed
is me team alcohol is you
q yeah state your argument i want you to
open with why you think alcohol is
superior to marijuana
well i think it's more i think it's the
ends it's really the beginning and the
ends of it that are better like i think
that one on alcohol
i find that i'm just more like i smoke
weed and i'm done like i'm on the couch
or i'm like just nodding or like i'm not
part of the conversation or anything
like that whereas with alcohol i'm very
much a part of the conversation and i
and i think there's something to
i like sitting around the bar drinking
way more than i like standing on a
sidewalk street corner smoking and
passing around the joint and stuff right
i just think the experience with alcohol
is better the taste of alcohol is better
and the ultimate as as long as you don't
go too far with alcohol the general
feeling of alcohol is better okay
see now this i'll say this about alcohol
it does put a pep in your step yeah
it does um
it can make you the life of the party
mm-hmm you know these are positives you
know for for some people when you drink
it
it it certainly takes you out of the bad
right like when you're or locks you in
right yeah i i would say okay so
speaking of the positives though
speaking to the positives uh you know
you're having a bad day a few drinks
will put you in a better mood usually
whatever you know
and there's something about it that you
let me i'm sorry i'm sorry i just i i
just wonder like i don't have this
feeling when i smoke weed i do have this
feeling of alcohol that i'm taking part
in like
a human tradition like when i'm in a bar
drinking with people i'm like there were
people in ancient [ __ ] egypt doing
the same [ __ ] probably making the same
jokes but like you know what i mean like
just in whatever you know language and
like like it's i just feel part of a
continuity and i know you i agree could
have the same argument can be made about
it but i just don't feel it's as
american as drinking well okay so then
i'll speak to that point
uh yeah you know like alcohol you're in
a bar drinking you can go man they did
this in the old west yeah the pioneers
of this country the people that
conquered
this country and i don't mean the bad
parts of the conquering i mean like but
just went out into the frontier and and
god knows what was going on out there
they were drinking in a bar in the
saloon in their tower that's the history
but weed's got a better history because
you got woodstock man you know wow what
a difference woodstock made
you guys were just so great at woodstock
that's your history with weed who needs
the people that conquered the frontier
in this country when you can be part of
the history of a bunch of hippies puking
and
having sex with each other and they're
stinking dirty ass dance
as some awful band goes on and on on the
stage
crosby stills and nash whatever
horseshit they booked at that festival
oh god you know what i mean so weed's
better in that sense
wait what
so you can't take it you know what else
i want to say too
i'm making good arguments for a weed let
me say this too
drinking will make you the life of the
party we just let you be the stupid
[ __ ] you always were deep down and
not care just walk around so fried
that you don't care and what's better
than a drug that makes you not care
about all of your flaws and faults well
isn't it well that is a positive right
you see what i'm doing here i'm doing a
thing here i i see the bit you're
definitely working a bit i got it
folks let's talk eyeglasses i love
eyeglasses why i need them
because i need them though i wear them
every day and because i wear them every
day i use them as a means to
express my style and uh and express who
i am
and i think that's very cool i like
great choices i like very customizable
options when it comes to eyewear and
that's why i like pear
pear is doing a lot of cool stuff and
offering you
some cool frames and combos that are
really going to let you express yourself
and find your style
through this part of the body
very nice uh i like the casper quite a
bit i also like another pair of frames
they have called the kirby very cool i
also like that their base frames are
starting at just 60 dollars including
the prescription lenses that's important
to me uh glasses eyeglasses you know
back in the day folks when i was your
age um you know you'd spend three four
hundred dollars with insurance to get
your glasses the fact that there's a
company like pear right now offering you
soup to nuts the whole thing for 60
bucks that's pretty incredible and
also it's not a limited experience there
are hundreds of top frame designs to
match whatever base frame you choose you
can change your glasses like you change
your clothes i like that maybe you can
get a few pairs if you want to spend a
little bit of cash for the price of what
it used to cost you for one
you can get started by choosing your
base frame with options from the square
to the cat eye okay every frame comes in
six different color ways including
classic black or you can remix it to
blue tortoise or whatever get crazy and
then you pick your top frames and build
a collection to match your personality
this is very cool i really like this
they're fiercely individual and they are
leading
by example or they're letting you lead
by example they're leading by example in
the eyeglass industry and then that's
going to let you lead by example in in
your personal life hey look at me i got
a base frame and then i put a top frame
on and i got a combo going here and i'm
mixing and matching and i'm making
things happen and you're not
look at you with your plain glasses i
got something happening here there are
companies out there that create an
illusion of choice in the eyewear
industry and they're keeping prices
artificially high pear eyewear has
forged their own way
and they're designing all their looks
in-house they're getting rid of all
these traditional nonsensical things and
they're making it tough for you to get
the pair of glasses you want so
go to
dot
pair
slash taste buds for 15 off your first
person purchase that's 15 off at p a i r
i wear dot com slash taste buds get
glasses as unique as you are one pair
infinite style starting at sixty dollars
when you visit pear eyewear dot com
slash taste buds for fifteen percent off
your first person folks uh
if you know me and you know this show
and you know what we talk about on this
show it's food it's a lot of food but
one thing that goes hand in hand with
food and it's also another thing we talk
about a lot of the show
is proper diet and weight loss and
that's where noom comes in i love what
noom is doing noom has created such a an
authentic
approach
to the experience of weight loss and and
and managing diet and that sort of thing
i i just have such a respect for what
they do and i found i find it and have
found it
so helpful because it's something that
i've always sort of had a hard time with
in in my life uh i think it's really
really great
that they have created a psychological
approach to diet and to weight loss
and let me talk about that a little more
uh with a little more illustration
unlike other restrictive diets
or workout programs noom
uses uh psychology to empower you
okay uh they're giving you practical
knowledge and skills that help you build
a smarter and more sustainable long-term
eating
uh regiment if you will
or eating behaviors the psychological
approach is based on scientifically
proven principles like cognitive
behavioral therapy which i'm a big fan
of cbt for you insiders
and it's just based on helping other
people under helping people in general
understand their relationship with food
and why they eat what they do
that's what i love so much about nume it
it helped me and it will help you
get why you're eating things at a
certain time
why you're craving certain things
uh why you're defining food in the way
you are it helped me get out of reward
eating it helped me get out of the zone
of uh indulging eating
entertainment eating
you know there's a lot of there are a
lot of terms for it and ways you could
refer to it but at the end of the day it
all comes back to the same place it's
not eating
properly uh and i think redefining your
relationship with food and understanding
what's going on up here is how you fix
those issues
and those bad habits more than 60
percent of users lose 5 or more of their
body weight weight by 16 weeks and more
than 60 percent of users engage with the
program keep that weight off
for more than a year that's a thing too
it's like a lot of these diets you see
it's fast weight loss but it's fast
weight gain back and neum is helping you
avoid that
they're grounded in science what they're
teaching you it's the heart of
everything they do science science
science they've published more than 30
peer-reviewed scientific articles that
inform users practitioners scientists
and the public about how their methods
work and how effective these methods are
and also here's some good news an off
day is totally okay and it won't set you
off course
newm weight gently helps you get back on
track
i love that because a lot of these other
diets that i'm sort of passively
referring to
i mean you hit an off day and forget it
that's it you're back to square one it's
terrible so
what i want you to do is sign up for a
trial today and get psychology-based
support and motivation to reach your
goals
by going to n-o-o-m.com
taste bud that's noom.com taste bud to
sign up for your trial
n o o m dot com slash taste bud
sign up for your trial start eating
correctly today by understanding how
this relates to this
uh wow you just really are i mean i'll
take i could take i told you i got a
knack for it yeah
i'll take weed i got it i want to keep
defending weed but why are you not
defending it at all everybody says
through this i just said it lets you be
the person you really are yeah i said
it's part of history all right i'll stop
i'll stop you could help with anxiety i
don't care it's your show i'll stop you
you wanna
write down
i'll defend it for real i'll defend it
for real as long as you know i don't
care either way no i don't know i'm just
here having fun i don't wanna do that i
had to break balls a little bit i'll
defend it for real though i will say
this about weed and i mean this very
sincerely
this is not a misdirection i'm not and
i'm guys the other stuff was just a joke
before you all start bombarding me with
comments i'm joking around
uh
the uh weed
we used to do a thing when i was in
college this is this is a hundred
percent true okay
and this is also the bummer to me not
bummer i i think it's really cool that
weed is legal now like it should be
obviously right sure and i also think
that if i could have told 18 year old me
hey dude you're going to be able to walk
across the street one day from your
apartment and buy weed without any
hassle whatever because i used to jump
through flaming hoops to get weed man
like when i was in college dude i never
smoked weed till i was 36 so i i never i
had never had any of that experience i
started when i was 17 and like dude we
would drive down to like the art museum
in philly because they had these like
drum circles
during the summer every saturday night
and you would just
start asking people does anybody have
weed around here my buddies you this is
not this is true my buddies when they
wanted weed and they couldn't find it
would drive into the worst neighborhood
in that they could find in the
neighboring town and just start going up
to people and saying does anybody around
here sell weed because it was like it
was it was drug dealing like you had to
sure you couldn't just get it you had to
find drug dealers and before it became
legal
in the in the more recent years even the
dealing was it was a different ball game
like before i left new york to live in
la you could have weed delivered on a
bike
and it was fully illegal but you could
get that done and it was that to me what
year was that
2015 2016 whatever
so that was nuts so i'm going back to
i'm going back to 96 97
so like
but what we did so first of all
when you got weed
oh my god it was so exciting it was so
exciting i remember my best one of my
best memories ever in college
was me and my roommate jim
sitting there was a graveyard behind our
dorm cool and after a night yeah after a
night of hopping to college parties yeah
we sat in a graveyard against a
headstone which i know is very
disrespectful at the time i grew up
playing in the cemetery no i got it i
didn't realize how disrespectful it was
it's disrespectful i don't think it is
if i was in that grave i'd be like hey
man guys thanks for stopping by like
i wouldn't find that disrespect i mean
you guys aren't like [ __ ]
smearing [ __ ] now like swastikas on it
no no no like you're just chilling out
we just sat against the headstone and we
smoked a joint and it was one of my
favorite college memories ever because
i remember we were laughing so hard
because my buddy goes
in the middle of it we were so stoned
and like right when you hit that point
where you're like holy [ __ ] i'm high
yeah he goes
look at this look at what we're doing my
parents are proud of me
[Laughter]
it's great and i never
i never
uh i i've had
i've had the best times on booze
okay like like the memories like that
even we were just talking about the beer
pong memory yeah i've had such amazing
memories but i never had the excitement
that i had when i got when i got weed it
was so exciting dude we used to do a
thing
where
we would all hang out me and two or
three of my other buddies we'd get
together in one of our dorm rooms
when we had weed
we were like 1920 when we did this and
it's gonna sound crazy but i'm telling
you it was awesome we would build a fort
in the dorm room like you did when you
were a kid oh okay and we would go
inside and get high in the fort and play
music
and like sit there listen it sounds nice
dude it was so fun and we'd put on like
i remember like uh my friend jerry was
one of the guys that we did it with
jerry put on
the danny elfman
cd of like all the music in a darkened
theater yeah music for dark and theater
and he put on one of the themes and it
had this long build up and we were like
what is this this is so weird and creepy
like what is this and he's like just
wait just wait and when it kicked in it
was the batman returns theme oh awesome
and it went into the batman theme
and we were so high in this fort he i
just got chills we were so high in the
fort and he goes it's batman dude
and we were like this is [ __ ] awesome
but like
i as as for all the pub crawls i've ever
done and like the the the hilarious
times playing beer pong and the basement
parties and the keg stands and whatever
i never on alcohol had moments like that
where they were like literally that i
would describe as magical where i was
like this is like i'm in another i'm in
another stratosphere right now dude like
i'm experiencing something that i
literally cannot experience with any
other
uh substance taking me out of whatever
you know yeah
but what about like
because i've been in bars where like the
whole bar
has broken out into like like a song
will come on right and everybody will
just start like singing like and stuff
like that and like that feels very
communal that's cool but it's always a
[ __ ] song it's never a good song it's
always come on eileen or [ __ ] okay
well it could be piano man i don't know
how do you feel about billy joel there
but i love billy joel piano man you're a
wrist okay all right you're over that
terrorist right there don't do that so
right okay he hates the song he's i
remember being sick
every [ __ ] time
so the the like i i know like after 9 11
we were in a bar calico jacks which is
still in business on 42nd yeah and uh it
was the first time i went out after 911
and i remember that feeling of like
we're gonna die tonight like we're
taking our lives into our own hands it
was like two weeks after 9 11 and every
week was like oh you're gonna get bomb
this week and i had a buddy that worked
for the fbi and he's like it's
definitely gonna happen again it was
like all that [ __ ] going on
and i remember going to the bar and like
we were all drinking and i was like
somebody just started a usa chat and it
was like and like now that sounds absurd
right but back then it was the healing
like we needed
and it was like all these drugs oh you
said it was so [ __ ] i remember that
feeling of being like wow man like and
that that wasn't i don't think you'd get
that on wheat i think that's like an
alcohol thing uh you don't you don't but
music
music music music hits me in a way on
weed that it doesn't hit me on anything
else um sometimes if uh you know i'm not
above a little dab of speed as he says
oh really
as he says in uh spotting a little dab
of speed will do
um
i got a train spot i want to i want to
get back to train spots remind me but a
little a little speed meets out yeah
when you got that body buzz going like
music sounds i've
i mean i know what speed is but like
what is speed comes in many forms okay
because i've never that's like i've
never done that i remember jay moore
said uh jaymore had a bit about when
you're in i forget what the bit was but
he described being in the zone okay and
he goes he goes you know when you're uh
he goes he goes you know when you're at
uh dave and busters he goes you know
you're at dave and busters you did a
couple key bumps you're on four beers
and you're just sinking those
three-pointers on the basketball is that
what it's like and he's like he's like
you know how good that feel like i feel
what the bit was but i was like i know
exactly what you mean okay so sometimes
when you're in that zone with a drug and
a and booze
the the music will hit me in a way where
you go oh my god life is [ __ ]
beautiful yeah but
that's of
you know you're making sauce you're
making gravy yeah you gotta hit the
ingredients perfect with weed
every time i smoked it and i listened to
music it was a wonderful experience it
and it still is like that once a year
when i take the edible and i have a few
drinks
i still get to that place
movies
on the other hand uh could go sideways
on me on weed i i movies i never enjoyed
because there'd be long periods of
silence
and i didn't know if the people i was
watching the movie with were enjoying it
or not so you got in your own head yeah
and then i just took the bug out yeah
especially if i picked a movie you know
sure well that's probably in you to be
in with just amplified by the weed right
yeah that's why i stopped because what
was in me was you know whatever but i'll
say that's the positive i'll say about
alcohol for me
alcohol does not amplify my worst
tendencies i i i am a guy that does have
i do have a little bit of a short fuse i
do get aggravated by things um and i do
and i am a guy that carries a lot on his
uh lack of shoulders
about you know i i you know i'm a
brooding kind of guy and um but when i
drink i don't go in that direction i
don't know why i just don't because i've
never had a weed experience that's ended
badly it's ended with me falling asleep
i've had plenty of alcohol experiences
that have ended in a fight
like either a fight in a bar which you
know is especially rare as you get older
but like certainly like if you're there
with your girlfriend or something like
that
like i'm gonna tell the story we can cut
it if you want us to what i saw you pop
off when
on weed no i don't know oh an alcohol
not alcohol
why what is it
well we were uh
we were at a casino recently
and
oh is that that guy's trying to throw me
out no
pimp was there too we were all there
we were playing at a table yeah you had
two you you were sitting in front of two
hands because your friend had gone to
the bathroom yeah and they wanted you to
watch the hand yeah yeah i remember this
and the dealer said you can't play two
hands and you go i'm not playing two hit
you right away you had a chip on your
shoulder and you go i'm not playing two
hands
my friend went to the bathroom they said
to watch the hands you just deal all
right like and the guy's like all right
and he deals you busted on both he
started screaming at him you screamed at
him and accused him of doing it on
purpose
and then shortly after that yeah i said
brian i gotta go to bed i'm tired and
you went oh [ __ ] you
know so that was a joke all that sounds
like a joke yeah
yeah but you were amped up as much but
yeah that was that was that was fun yeah
but that ended with me dancing on the
stage with those girls yeah that was
that's awesome yeah that's awesome yeah
that was fun so my point is and i don't
say it to judge for whatever reason i
don't go to that place with booze yeah
and i would think i would that's what's
funny you're the calmest nicest sweetest
guy i know right well i don't know about
that
you're your top five easily that i've
ever met okay all right thank you that's
nice i wouldn't have said i wouldn't
have guessed that you're a pleasant guy
you know i remember once uh
two comics russ many hilarious guy tom
chalu uh also hilarious guy russ we were
on a show once it caroline's together i
remember this is the greatest compliment
i've ever heard
russ pointed at tom chalu and he goes
this guy if i'm ever in a crisis
situation that's the guy i want there no
one is more soothing than this man
yeah and uh and i was like wow what an
amazing compliment but i would apply
that compliment to you because i'm like
you're a guy i'd want a round if
something went sideways because you you
you're you're a calming presence so
thank you that's very nice
because i'm a sort of a dark
i'm sort of a dark whatever but when i
drink
i don't get amped when you drink
sometimes you do it's a very f it's
funny that we go in kind of unexpected
ways sometimes not always but you know
no no no no if i if i if i'm like i just
get like a sloppy drunk like i'm sure
like i remember like what you're talking
about the bar like i
i in my head i'm positive i was like
trying to [ __ ] be funny
and it just doesn't come out that way
because i'm a drunk [ __ ] [ __ ]
which is why you know i don't drink i i
can't drink that much anymore
i just don't do it um
i mean
but i'll tell you i'll tell you because
it's not the losing money that bothers
me like if i go to if i lose
i'm not there to win i don't gamble to
win i think with both i think with both
these substances yeah i'll tell you this
that's another pro i'd give to weed
yeah gambling on weed
i think
great
because you have a way stronger chance
of locking in and really like
i always found that sort of thing when i
was high great
i always had a problem with people
driving high for the same reason i have
a problem with people driving drunk i'm
no saint in my life i've done both i
know i shouldn't have and i never will
again
uh but like my point is is you know i'm
not i'm not chastising but overall i do
have a problem with it you know what i
mean
and um but
so i hate when people say i drive better
when i'm high that's to me that's a very
stupid thing to say but
i will agree that weed does give you a
mechanical focus
um you know that's why a lot of people
smoke before they work out or they smoke
before they clean the house oh man man
don't even told me a story where he'll
smoke like joints before he works out
and i'll be like
how do you do it i couldn't do that
right you could work out on weed
i couldn't i'm just saying people do i
get why people here but like some do
edibles before the gym really it's
awesome yeah wow what is it just
you just super focus and the music is
way better
i guess my closest example would be uh
video games like a video game like when
i smoked weed i would get like i would
be locked in dude like you you would be
like having the game of your [ __ ]
life yeah
that booze
that's not happening you know what i
mean
plus you gotta get up and like refill
your glass you gotta go get another beer
something about weed you just like put
the joint down and keep going but the
downside and this is the pro and con of
both right i think the pro of both of
these substances is when you're in the
zone
in the right environment and it's
working nothing is better when it goes
sideways on you yeah even in what you
perceive to be the right environment
there's nothing worse so with alcohol
we've already covered like it can lead
to the bar fight the bar experience can
be everybody singing the irish song
together and swaying or whatever you
know
like we all wish it was instead of don't
stop believing you know what i mean it's
never a cool like irish
whatever it's always some like i said
just [ __ ] [ __ ] song from the 80s
anyway yeah um you're right about that
but that's perfect right that's the
perfect scenario that but unfortunately
that's also the place where the brawl
breaks out sometimes for me with weed
the pro is like i said the music the
lock in oh my god i feel it i i feel the
notes maybe something's going through me
right yeah but i've also had a full-on
panic attack when we'd hit me too hard
at a concert where i had to leave and
the next concert
it kills me they're my favorite band and
i've seen them since but the fu manchu i
got the shirt hanging right out there um
they're they're still in a rock band and
their fu manchu is dare i say righteous
righteous
they're just the greatest band of all
time i listen to them
they're awesome i've heard of them and
i've had the pleasure of like kind of
getting to know them over instagram like
which has been really nice but like
uh not know them but like we we made we
connected and they got they're cool guys
it was really cool what made you freak
out
i don't i was in i was already into the
period of my life where i wasn't really
smoking but i was new to la and la had
dispensaries and i got my card just for
kicks my medical card for kicks because
i was like i couldn't believe this was a
thing
and um my friends came to visit and the
last night we were going to see fu
manchu it was the big night
and i ate
too much of an edible and i didn't think
it was gonna hit me
and then i was drinking
i was drinking i was drinking heavier
than i normally would drink
so like i drank two
in a matter of probably 10 minutes i
drank two double jack daniels on the
rocks
because because you're at a concert and
it's so crowded in the line so long
i went up you know i'm like give me two
and i downed one and i think i might
have gotten a two to go i made this
mistake a couple of times yeah so you're
sitting there and you're drinking and
then they came out and i'm like this is
[ __ ]
they opened with my favorite song like i
was like this is the best thing ever
and like all of a sudden you know the
room starts closing in and you start
getting that feeling like you took too
much acid or something and you're like
you're on the bad trip and you're like
i'm having a panic attack i have to
leave
and the idea of getting from that place
where i was standing
to the outside to get into an uber
was so terrifying
and we're at the troubadour dude the
troubadour's not a big place yeah i mean
that yeah you know like it wasn't like
we were in some you know god forbid if
we had been at a stadium show
you've been [ __ ] i would have been
[ __ ] yeah i would have been the guy
they had to carry out
what did you take oh look at this more
bastard yeah you know
because i literally was like i need to
close my eyes i had a bad mushroom trip
once when i was 21 and it was the worst
thing i've ever expected well what's
that like talk me through a bad mushroom
trip
i
we took these mushrooms
it was when i first moved to austin i
was with a friend named don and then a
girl he was dating that i didn't really
know at the time
and i
what i knew of her i didn't really like
we didn't really get along too well sure
and so that's right there you're off to
open yeah there's a bad vibe in the mix
already but i didn't know i was i was
like 21 i didn't know like that that was
you know you feel invincible at that age
and every time you did it before it was
fun so what's going to happen right
so i took the the mushrooms
and we dressed up it was halloween we
dressed up we were gonna go and do all
this halloween stuff in the middle of
austin
and uh
i remember i came out of the bathroom
and i've always had this thing where i i
metabolize it really fast and nobody
ever believes me but i do
i was we took them and 10 minutes later
i was like wow i'm feeling these things
already they're they're kicking in
and they were like there's no way
there's no way there's i'm like i'm
telling you guys i have like the body
tingles yeah this isn't in my head like
i know
and they were like well we don't feel
anything yet and then
we went to the first thing
and as we were walking to it i was
feeling
again it's like everything's closing in
and then but do you not have the
wherewithal on mushrooms to be like i i
know what's going on this is mushrooms
[ __ ] on my brother you would think
that right you would think that i would
think that you like it makes so much
sense right now right yeah but you just
can't
you can say it to yourself it doesn't
help though it just doesn't you're so
gone dude yeah you know what i mean when
you're having a panic attack you know
you're having a panic attack but you
can't go i'm just having a panic attack
your bo your brain is going i'm dying
right now you know what i mean like and
you're you're just not gonna beat that
thing so so we went the girl don was
dating she goes let's go to the the
capitol lawn because it's really
beautiful okay the capitol building and
we'll sit on the lawn i was like and i
remember being like yeah that's a great
idea that's a great idea because i
remember thinking oh sitting down i'll
feel better grass the night sky the air
and we sat down and i turned to my
friend don and i go
dude this is hitting me really fast and
really hard in a really bad way
and i go when i close my eyes it's worse
and when so when i was when my eyes were
open i was looking at stuff it was all
just kind of like
and then when i closed my eyes i was
getting like those light hallucinations
where you see almost like lasers you
know
my friend don
i mean just should be in the guinness
book of world records for the worst
thing a person has ever said in a moment
he goes
i don't know man that's never happened
to me before and i'm like uh
really dude and dude the night went from
there we were trying to go see evil dead
2 at midnight that was the big goal
and i finally got my [ __ ] together
enough to get up and walk to the movie
theater and we got there and i sat down
and i was like i cannot deal with evil
dead too right now it's too much
so i left and next to the theater next
to it best and show was playing ah
that's great yeah it was the new
christopher yesterday time it's
hysterical yeah well i went in to try to
watch that and i was like oh this will
be great i'll feel good
and i was already going and i walked in
and it was the part where they're
interviewing eugene levy and he goes
i have two left feet that's not a
euphemism i was actually born with two
lefty in the camera fans i used to do a
feet and i was like this is freaking me
out worse
than the evil dead was so i left
dude there were so many things that were
that happened on this it was so crazy
and i finally dude this is 1990
wow no i'm sorry this is
2 000. okay this is right before 9 11.
and um i i i was 2 000 so dude there's
there was no uber
boston was not a place that had tons of
cabs
so i was trying to get a cab you
actually back then you had to call for a
cab sure i remember and i went into a
video arcade that was open really late
because i guess because they were
showing these labels
on them and [ __ ] like that they didn't
have a pay phone um
i couldn't find a pay phone
i asked the guy to use his phone the
phone didn't work the guy that ran the
arcade he like let me go into the office
to use the phone
tripping my balls off dude he left and
shut the door on me yeah and i thought
he was gonna like try to like kill me or
something
and i was freaking out and then the
phone didn't work it was just like a
comedy of errors i went outside
i there was a people on a date sitting
on steps they had a cell phone that was
the thing too i didn't have a cell phone
yeah this is bad way back then yeah
they let me use the cell phone but they
were like dude we don't know a number
for a cab and if you didn't know the
number that was it back then you
couldn't search it there was no there
was no browsers in your phone or
anything and i was just it was just the
universe it was a nokia yeah it was one
gut punch after the next the universe
just being like dude you're not getting
out of this and just by the grace of god
a cab went by i hailed it nice dude he
goes where do you live i told him
i was sweating i took the window down
and he just goes where are you from man
i go philly and he's like oh i'm from
philly and i was like really
and we just started talking and it it
was what i talked to down he didn't even
know he was talking about yeah that's
great and i was like dude i missed the
cheesesteaks man he's like yeah dude you
can't get one down here man and like we
were just talking it was so great and
then
i got back to my apartment and i
remember i was tripping my balls off but
now it's just normal tripping like where
i could handle it yeah you know and then
i was kind of like having fun finally
because i was home and safe and i
remember i put on
i was like i can't put anything on
that's gonna freak me out
and i put on andrew dice clay i was like
this is the only thing i can think of
that's not gonna freak me out i
understand completely what it is yeah
what you see is what you get right
that's it like and and i just put that
on and i was laughing and i was and that
was the rest of my night i told that
story
in even greater detail on
uh craig ferguson's radio show
and he was like this is a movie we
should write a movie about this and me
and this kid joe who was his co-host
wrote a screenplay get out of here about
that one night
yeah about the one night and like every
one of those beats i just told you
becomes an actual insane moment in the
movie all right
but then it becomes like this whole
cosmic thing it's actually a really cool
screenplay
dust that off i i will i i should i
should but uh i was telling the story i
remember ferguson just being like [ __ ]
mate jesus christ
[Laughter]
um he's a good dude anyway i never met
him great dude yeah um all right
we we we i i nicely defended weed i
think
yeah rough at the beginning well it was
a joke at the beginning
all right i think you did great buddy
yeah he did good i think yeah i was
joking at the beginning definitely
trashed mushrooms that sounds awful
i didn't even mean to
sorry mushroom people don't get mad at
me i know they can be great but i just
that was a bad experience that one time
but usually it's been good
uh all right let's see who wins
we're going to the polls so i'm alcohol
your alcohol we got almost ten thousand
votes here wow
every time i do with sally we crap out
like four thousand votes oh wow all
right well this is a good sign all right
oh god what yeah what
wait no wait alcohol one last time right
oh let's but let's see i'm not sure
i forget
i forget too i feel like it was way
closer than that last time
holy [ __ ] i thought in my head i want to
read the percents real quick oh sorry
yeah jesus sorry guys i'm dumbfounded
alcohol 59.6 percent weed 40.40
it's a much greater margin than i
thought it was going to be and i got to
tell you people i can't buy a win on
this podcast anymore because this counts
now towards my losses which i'm i'm way
behind i'm getting the [ __ ] kicked out
of me and then i defend weed almost as a
goof
right because i went so hard on it last
time and i lose again
but the way you guys do this is like
these people are not swayed by your
arguments no so so why do you why do you
feel even that you're taking a loss five
percent margin last time yeah
no i'm because i you your win is based
on the poll that's it yeah right but
that's but like
so the argument almost doesn't even
matter
no the argument does i think
we've tried to figure out a way we could
revisit the poll after the argument's
been made that sounds right like a
pre-game post like a pre a pre-show post
and an after the episode drops one i
gotta tell you swayed our argument i got
to tell you this buddy
the it was a five percent margin last
night yeah this is a much greater margin
also given the response
that came at me after i trashed weed you
would think weed would have taken it i
can't believe alcohol won by that much i
think i'll turn in the fans of this show
[Laughter]
i'm seeing a lot of comments that are
like you know what i used to hate the
rosa but he really grew he really grew
on me
who would hate you you'd be surprised
well you wouldn't be really i would i i
i take to you
all right all right that's a nice that's
a nice uh nice win on your part good
good job hey man i wonder what my record
is because at this point i've had i
think i lose to sal fairly often
i i think i lose to him often do it
again like i don't feel bad about it no
no i don't feel bad either i just it's
just hilarious that i switched teams at
the last minute i should defend weed and
i still uh
um do you have anything you want to plug
uh no not anything all right um well we
got the show plugs right but but let me
just extra plug i'm taping the special
in houston texas folks when uh april
19th and april i'm sorry may 19th and
may 22nd
i will be in houston did i say austin oh
god i [ __ ] this whole plug up guys let
me start the plug over i'm taping my new
hour special in houston texas at the
come and take it festival which is being
held at the secret group which is a
great venue in texas
i shoot may 19th and may 22nd on the
20th and 21st i'm shooting over to
austin to run that same hour four times
at the creek and cave
uh before i go back and tape the second
show for the special in houston so come
to one or all of those things um
and i'm doing this all on myself
nobody's behind me i'm paying for it
yeah i'm self-producing it
uh
and it's gonna be called i never
promised you a rose garden
and then what do you do you put it on
the website and people go like buy it
we'll probably put it up i don't know
yet but we'll probably yeah it's it's
coming somewhere yeah somewhere that the
fans can get to it let's put it that way
all right uh check out the merch yeah oh
yeah and check out our merch page it's
up what's the link
it's on sal's website it's on chow's
website okay so go to sal volcano dot
com selficanocomedy.com
comedy.com and and you can find the
merch page with the taste buds merch
there's hay bait merch there too if sal
started doing like horror movies would
he would he get salvocanna
salvocanohara.com like like is it is it
like seen his act i think it should be
that oh
oh i've seen his act i i laughed i liked
it i know i'm kidding no it's all right
you can let it little poison leak out
it's okay uh all right folks that's
that's our show oh the tradition you
have to say the winners to say i still
love you
i i still love you i love you too all
right
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds